jetzt wollen wir uns aber noch mal
gemeinsam das bereits eben angesprochene
video von anonymous anschauen
[Musik]
greetings raschen präsident wladimir
putin grüße an russlands präsident
wladimir putin wir haben offenkundig
darauf gewartet dass sie auf unsere
jüngste anfrage antworten wir werden
langsam ungeduldig weil wir den eindruck
haben dass sie uns ignorieren deshalb
haben wir entschieden eine spezielle
operation auf sie zugeschnitten
durchzuführen es ist eine art geschenk
erinnern sie sich noch an die zeit als
das kollektiv 2018 mehr russische
webseiten abschaltete müsste putin do
you remember when used to afghanistan
mister putin erinnern sie sich als sie
in afghanistan einen sensiblen datensatz
des ministeriums für verteidigung
verloren haben dieser wurde geliebt vom
kollektiv anonymous dieser wurde geliebt
vom kollektiv anonymous dieser datensatz
enthielt e mail adressen und passwörter
diese informationen wurden auf twitter
veröffentlicht und sind jetzt öffentlich
zugänglich schämen sie sich dass sie
jüngst finnland und schweden bedrohten
sie drohten damit in diese länder
einzudringen wenn sie der nato beitreten
wir haben daraufhin die webseite des
föderalen anti monopol dienstes kreml
russland und viele weitere andere
webseiten der russischen regierung
abgeschaltet vladimir putin
diese gehören zu den stars vladimir
putin es ist kein zufall dass anonymous
plant das aufzudecken was seit jahren
verborgen ist sie und ihr ganzes
korruptes system wird die ganze macht
von anonymous zu spüren bekommen es ist
nur eine frage der zeit bis wir
aufdecken welche schmutz sie vor der
öffentlichkeit verstecken es wird keine
lüge ungesühnt bleiben wie verlangt von
ihnen die rechte der ukrainischen bürger
zu akzeptieren sie haben versagt leben
zu schützen sie haben versagt bei ihren
staatsbürgerlichen und moralischen
verpflichtungen als offizieller beamter
und sie haben diejenigen die sie
vorgeben zu regieren in ihrem ständigen
mangel an ehrlichkeit im stich gelassen
das ist ein aufruf an anonymous
mitglieder es ist zeit vladimir putin
den geldhahn endgültig abzudrehen bitte
unternimmt alle anstrengungen die nötig
sind und lasso keine option unversucht
vladimir putin
sie haben die möglichkeit sich zu
erklären in den wind geschlagen sie
haben entschieden einen viel größeren
krieg zu beginnen wir werden ihn niemals
ihre lügen vergeben wir werden die
lieben die durch ihre lieben verloren
gegangen sind niemals vergessen es ist
zu spät um uns aufzuhalten
putin bekommt also ordentlich gegenwind
wir wollen auf weitere reaktionen aus
dem internet schauen kehrer ortmann hat
das wichtigste zusammengefasst
vielen dank liebe ferien wir wollen
direkt anfangen mit einem tritt von
einem spd politiker von fritz felgentreu
der nämlich gesehen hat dass der
ukrainische präsident innerhalb der
letzten 24 stunden mehr als eine million
neue follower auf twitter bekommen hat
eine million neue follower n24 schon
übermorgen hat er mehr als putin
schreibt er dazu jetzt könnte man meinen
wen interessieren jetzt gerade die
follower auf twitter oder in den
sozialen medien es heißt einfach nur
dass er jetzt einfach gerade einen
wahnsinnig großen rückhalt aus der
ganzen welt spürt und dadurch eben ja
auch noch mehr die kraft hat jetzt
weiter eben für sein land zu kämpfen wir
haben gestern den ganzen tag schon
darüber berichtet wie er sich in den
sozialen medien oder auch in
videobotschaften an sein volk immer
wieder gewarnt hat und ja auch in der
nacht sich wieder an sein volk gewandt
hat und so im mut verteilt hat und das
ist eben wirklich ja da bekommt er eben
auch den rückhalt aus den sozialen
medien dass er da eben unterstützung
bekommt ein weiterer tweet ist hier von
dennis trotzki er schreibt es ist gerade
die beschissene zeit er war ohne frage
aber auch zeit der unglaublichen
einigkeit der ukrainischen nationen
sowie das nicht weniger beeindruckenden
mitwirken der zivilgesellschaft putin
hat echt keine ahnung mit wem er sich
hier anlegt und dieser tweet zeigt auch
einfach noch mal dass eben die ganze
internet gemeinschaft eben für diese für
das ende des krieges steht und sich eben
gegen putin stellt ein weiterer tweet
den wir hier vorbereitet haben denn
nicht nur der ukrainische präsident
wird jetzt gerade in den sozialen medien
sehr gefeiert hier juli schneller
schreibt das ist eine politik bereit
schon jetzt ist witali klitschko neben
selensky eben ein held der stunde putins
schergen werden sich mit ihm als
anführer der käfer verteidigung mehr als
eine blutige nase holen sein mut ist
beispiellos ein champion der
europäischen werte und vorbild für alle
und es zeigt ein aktuelles bild noch mal
von vitali klitschko hier aus dem krieg
eben aus der ukraine wir haben ja
gestern schon das große interview mit
ihm gehabt mit ihm und seinem bruder von
paul ronzheimer geführt und ja heute
nacht dann auch noch mal ein update wir
wissen eben dass er eben auch für seine
stadt kämpft und da eben ja keine keine
keine zeit vergehen lässt ein weiterer
rat schmid und das ist eben ganz
auffällig jetzt im moment in den
sozialen medien ist das ja immer wieder
nach sanktionen gefordert wird und
dieser user schreibt liebe deutsche bahn
wäre es möglich ankommende menschen aus
der ukraine ohne fahrschein fahren zu
lassen so wie es in polen bereits
praktiziert wird dieser user denkt also
eben schon an die ganzen flüchtlinge wir
haben ja in den letzten tagen schon
darüber berichtet über 100.000 menschen
haben sich jetzt schon auf den weg
gemacht eben die ukraine zu verlassen
weil es eben zu gefährlich ist sie haben
jetzt den mut gefasst dann auch ihre
heimat zu verlassen um eben dann in
sicherheit zu kommen und wir haben es
hier in dem tweet gelesen polen hat es
bereits möglich gemacht dass dies die
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine sich
dort eben schon selbst bewegen können
ohne daneben ein fahrschein beziehen zu
müssen und das fordert dieser user eben
auch von der deutschen bahn ein weiterer
user fordert unsere bund ist die
ehemalige bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
auf können sie bitte ihr gutes rutsche
russisch für eine direkte ansprache an
die menschen in russland nutzen jeder
appell hilft jeder versuch ist es wert
wir wissen ja die menschen in russland
bekommen einfach im moment keine
richtigen informationen über die
aktuelle situation hier im krieg
deswegen haben wir uns bei bild auch
dazu entschlossen einige unserer artikel
auf russisch zu übersetzen damit sich
die menschen eben wirklich ordentlich
informieren können wir wissen auch eben
die menschen und russland sind teilweise
wirklich in gefahr wenn sie auch nur
aussprechen dass es sich hier um einen
krieg herrscht weil wladimir putin diese
neben verharmlosen will aber jetzt
dieser user schreibt eben auch nochmal
an angela merkel dass sie jetzt
eventuell ihr russisch ihre ihre
ansprache auch noch mal halten könnte
auf russisch damit diese die menschen
eben erreicht das kollektiv peng
schreibt wenn ihr nicht wisst was ihr
tun könnt steigt ins auto am besten in
einen kleinbus und tod leute an der
polnisch ukrainischen grenze ab von
berlin ca 9 stunden fahrt viele menschen
fragen sich ja im moment was können wir
hier tun wird zum beispiel bei bild
haben auch immer gesagt wir wollen viel
berichten damit eben die menschen ja
sich auch unterstützt fühlen dieser
mensch dieses kollektiv schreibt jetzt
eben dass man eben theoretisch sich auch
selber sogar in das auto setzen kann und
die flüchtlinge eben abholen kann wir
haben aber auch von vielen aktionen
gehört das eben ganze busse jetzt gerade
losgeschickt werden an die grenzen um
den menschen dort eben vor ort zu helfen
um zb auch lebensmittel und kleidung
ihnen rüber zu bringen um sie da eben zu
unterstützen und ein letzter tweet noch
von jan fleischhauer den kolumnisten er
schreibt eine form des opportunismus die
das zeug hat sprichwörtlich zu werden
neue redewendungen für besonders dreiste
wendigkeit beim umschlagen den
politischen verhältnissen die schwesig
machen und das zitiert hier nochmal bzw
we posted einen schmied der
ministerpräsidenten manuela schwesig die
sich eben gegen gerhard schröder
gestellt hat wobei sie ja eben selbst
und wir haben es gestern auch schon
berichtet unser bild meinung chef
philipp jakob hat einen sehr
eindringlichen kommentar dazu
geschrieben den sie natürlich auch auf
bild de finden das eben manuela schwesig
sich in den vergangenen jahren immer
putin verharmlost hat uns auch seine
kriegskassen gefühlt hat und jetzt eben
versucht irgendwie auch solidarität zu
zeigen aber dass eben nicht wirklich
glaubwürdig ist ja und mit diesen worten
gebe ich erstmal wieder zurück zu dir
viel